reaction video alert we have a new
reaction video for you of what it must
have been like for don jr to drunk dial
his friend after cassidy hutchinson
humiliated his dad during the january 6
committee hearing we were originally
going to hire an actor to play an
inebriated or hi don jr but then when we
saw the actual video that don jr posted
no actor was needed
comedian and midas touch contributor
gabe sanchez produces and acts in this
incredible gem enjoy oh god what does he
want now
the january 6th committee they brought
out a star witness yeah cassidy
hutchinson someone who's at the
epicenter of everything cassidy
hutchinson her name cassidy hutchinson
don't even listen 25 years old so at the
time you know she was in all of the real
conversations there's a lot of photos of
her in meetings with meadows and your
dad she says that after leaving his
january 6 speech donald trump
essentially assaulted
two united states secret service guards
yeah and it was confirmed by other
secret service guards trump is basically
james bond more like a toddler having a
tantrum if you know my dad he's a big
dude yeah we can agree on that donald
trump
magazine didn't didn't steal the
presidential limo because the secret
service stopped him i'm i'm shocked yeah
you and peter alexander one of the
people one of the other officers tony
ornato junior i'm gonna stop you right
there okay ornato has been caught in
line on multiple occasions now would you
stop bothering me
i mean
that's the mag occult for you keep your
kids keep your family far far away
and make sure you subscribe right now to
the midas touch youtube channel thank
you